moi je crois que c'est très gênant parce
que indépendamment si vous voulez des
éléments juridiques
il y a en france quelque chose qui
s'appelle la discrétion religieuses on
parlera de pas comme ça sa religion non
reconnais mais c'est un fait une
agression
c'est une agression beaucoup et je le
figaro j'ai beaucoup de respect pour le
pour le monde arabo-musulman sauf que
c'est pas la france où d'accord donc si
effectivement certains se se sentent
gênés mais pas là de vivre de vivre leur
religion et leur culture en france parce
que la france a une autre identité
ils sont libres d'aller vivre cette
identité ailleurs j'ajoute que c'est que
cette dame pour qui j'ai le plus grand
respect et vais effectivement elle et
elle et elle préside une association je
crois qu'elle a fondée qui s'appelle
tabassum qui est une fondation qui est
très proche des frères musulmans avant
donc effectivement c'est une femme c'est
une famille sélam cfa levier c'est que
c'est une islamiste et je considère que
le voile c'est un étendard du fascisme
islamique c'est une svastika au féminin
donc je n'en veux pas en france point
final voilà un spécial est alors
dernière dernière chose vous vous qui y
est vous avez dit que effectivement
cette phase est cette dame ray ressemble
au quartier mais la france moi non non
ressemblent vous avez la sélection
régionale donc c'est malheureux non non
non il ya un truc que je pige pas parce
que d'être d'habitude quand on dit
le remplacement vous êtes les premiers à
pousser des cris d'orfraie en dix ans le
pas le remplacement c'est un concept des
sram droite alors s'il ressemble au
quartier on doit sous-entendre que le
quartier majoritairement habité par
donc s'ils voulaient ge j'avais ça
j'aurais s'aggrave autrement quand je
vous demande d'arrêter donc au départ
les là pendant trois minutes déjà
d'objets vous dire ce que disent et
hélène ça n'a rien à voir
vous dites vous vous transformez tout
c'est insupportable elle parlait de la
fiche elle dit voilà mine de rien il ya
parlé des quatre personnes qui
représente le quartier qui représente là
il arrive le micro cause mi6 qui
trouvent que l'affiché très belle etc
amelia croco une majorité procès qui je
pense que vous radical d'extrême droite
ou à ni islamistes pourraient adhérer à
ce qu'on a mis en haut à gauche de la
fiche je crois que tout le monde sait
lire différents mini pour oui c'est même
penser que ces personnes à la plagne à
des surenchères nomme différentes doit
rester des françaises moi je ne pense
pas l'allemande évolue vous savez le
poids non mais moi je suis né de georges
frêche qui était une liste de questions
à poser mais je ne veux pas que la
france évolue dans ce sens là je
mentionne ça réunit d'anciennes non si
c'est pas la france à 7 à la pause
c'est ma seule hélène hélène hélène
pourquoi elle n'est pas là aujourd'hui
parce que sarah tout simplement elle n'a
pas être un porte étendard de ce qu'on
ne veut pas montrer à travers cette
affiche exactement contre ce que vous
dites monsieur bien ce n'est pas
possible c'est une jeune femme qui est
intégrée dans ma société manifestement
pas qu'est-ce que lundi serait
maintenant vous êtes intégré à quoi
monsieur lescure s'est bien intégré à la
française et la république s'est jamais
plus décalé de mort ça c'est pas
l'identité française je ne sera jamais